it is endlessly fascinating what is
going on with Mike Pence over the last
10 days or so we learned from the
Washington Post that it wasn't merely
Mike Pompeo Trump's Secretary of State
who was on that now infamous phone call
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president vice president Mike Pence was
also on the call putting him fully into
the fray and right away / NBC News vice
president Mike Pence received a letter
from House Democrats on Friday demanding
that he turn over documents related to
the president's dealings with Ukraine
mother as he refers to her is not going
to like this one bit that we can be sure
of now before we dig into what we know
there are two views on this one view is
Pence is genuinely as much a part of the
rampant criminality as his Trump he's
complicit he's involved he's a major
player that's view number one the other
view is well Pence is sort of involved
but really it's Trump who's going to
make sure to take pence down with him if
he goes down simply because that's the
kind of person that Donald Trump is and
one reason that one might start to think
that maybe Trump is going to make sure
to take pence down is that he actually
said at that September 25 press
conference at the UN he said Mike
Pence's conversations with Ukraine out
of the blue he said should also be
looked into you can look at those
they're perfect but of course no one was
talking about them they're getting hit
hard on this witch-hunt because when
they look at the information it's a joke
impeachment for that I think you should
ask for VP Pence's conversation because
he had a couple of conversations also I
could take a lot of time they were all
perfect and when you see little Adam
Schiff go out and lie and lie and stand
it that my smart guy by the way so the
question is is this another unforced
error by Donald Trump or is Donald Trump
slowly but surely starting to pull Mike
Pence into this thing deliberately and
then when you look at it Trump is
actually right Mike
Pence is in way over his head on this
entire thing it's becoming the fort
reasons for lack of a better term Trump
Pence Pompeo and we'll see who gets that
fourth spot in the band before we know
it I'm sure
Pence's team is saying oh yeah well
Pence was strongly pressing the
Ukrainians to investigate corruption but
he had no idea that it was because Trump
wanted Biden smeared it's already
getting weird when you start to see
spokespeople for the President and Vice
President starting to have implicitly
conflicting points of view if not direct
conflict at this point in time and in
the end we get to this question are we
better off with Pence or are we worse
off with pence could pence be removed
along with Donald Trump but there's
really only one answer impeachment won't
remove either of them it will be up to
us in November of 2020 more and more
people are angry with me saying David
don't write off removing Trump senators
might vote to remove him I'm not writing
it off but I'm writing it off as a
strategy to win because it's both
unlikely and it's out of our control
you can come up with all sorts of
scenarios once you pull Penson will
impeach Trump but not pence allow pence
to resign so that a new VP can be
confirmed before Trump's removal who
then becomes president of the United
States you can go through all of these
scenarios the two most likely realities
are Pence is almost as big a player here
as is Donald Trump and neither is going
to be removed by impeachment it's not
impossible but it's unlikely to happen
and it's not something we can strategize
around so it is up to us to vote in
November of 2020 and make sure that
these people are removed if you disagree
with me on the strategy let me know I
understand people who are saying I
shouldn't already have as a foregone
conclusion that nothing will go anywhere
with impeachment okay as a strategy the
focus needs to be voting them out and
using any information that we can to
expose the corrupt and ridiculous nature
of what they've done in order to get
more people interested in voting in
November
20:20 i'm on instagram at david pakman
the show is on instagram at david pakman
show quick break back after this